okay guys welcome back we are in our
next video here and we are going to be
doing some some dynamic simulations and
i kind of want to just show you what
we're going to be doing
and here is the video that i came up
with for this project
[Music]
let's watch it one more time
and as you can see we've got some nice
texture here
and i'm going to show you where i got
all of these items here shortly
so what you can see happening here is
that we have our main animation which is
our falling of our bullets we also have
the animation of our camera moving
backwards and then the secondary or
overlapping animation um
is the bullets actually interacting with
the environment and each other and so
you can see the bullets kind of bouncing
off and then moving as they roll
so
let's get out of here
okay guys here we are inside of our next
cinema 4d scene
this is going to be our dynamic
simulation scene i have a scene kind of
already set up for you guys here as you
can see we have our
death stroke mask here we have our two
revolvers that are just the same
revolver just copied over and then the
second revolver basically what i did was
change the scale in z so that it could
be symmetrically
um symmetrical on the other side and
then i also have my little ground plane
here where everything is set sitting
and i also have my bullets here they're
sitting right here
and if you look
up here
above everything and you'll see why this
is here i have this little cone here and
let me show you kind of how i made that
basically what i did is i came up here
i created a cylinder
let's move this off to the side so we
can just pay attention to it
and then i went into the caps and i
turned that off and i basically
you know kind of scaled this down a
little bit and then i i hit this little
button there to make the whole thing
editable
and then i went into my edge mode and i
selected my edges double clicked on and
i hit t on the keyboard to scale to kind
of open it up and kind of create this
funnel and then i also clicked on this
one and scaled it down
so that's how i made that little funnel
and you'll get you'll you'll understand
why i made that as we continue on
so the first thing that we need to do is
we actually need to look at the dynamic
system inside of cinema 4d over the
overall dynamic system and the way we do
that is we go into our project settings
or we hit control d on the keyboard we
go into the dynamic section and this is
where we will actually see everything
okay so the first thing we want to look
at is
the general area and right now we can
see that um i have my gravity set to 100
the default for this is if you reset
that to default is a thousand i think
that's way too much for our purposes so
we can just set that to a hundred there
okay this time scale at 100 is good um
and everything else is looks looks
pretty good here next we can actually go
to the expert tag
and what we're going to do is
we are going to change the steps per
frame to 20
and what steps per frame are is
basically the resolution of your entire
dynamic simulation so this starts out at
let's go back and say ready set to
default that starts out at five and
you'll notice that when you're doing
dynamic simulations sometimes when
objects collide with themselves or other
objects they'll have some funny
movements to them and that's because
your steps for frame the resolution of
the animation is too low now one thing i
was taught rule of thumb wise is that um
you should never go above 30 on your
steps per frame if you're going above 30
on your steps per frame something's
wrong with your overall dynamic system
and that needs to be fixed okay so with
that said i am going to
continue on the collision margin should
be at point three the
uh default to that is one the what the
collision margin is doing
is
uh anytime there's a dynamic cpu
simulation and one object is colliding
with another one it's trying to figure
out how exactly how close that object is
uh the surface of this object is to this
one so that collision margin will
actually you know tighten it up if it
looks like the object is floating above
the surface or something like that so
that's where you you would mess with
that and we also want to set the scale
to 50 and then these are the settings
for the we don't have anything for the
random seed but all of this stuff is
pretty uh standard i didn't change any
of the rest so the next thing we want to
look at is our visualization we want to
enable that so i can kind of show you
guys what's happening in the background
in cinema 4d when you're working with
dynamics so if i grab one of my bullets
here i'm going to
look i'm going to grab both my bullets
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
i've already placed them into a cloner
and if you look at my cloner it's going
to be in a grid array
so let's go here there's our cloner it's
in a grid away we see our bullets here
and what i'm going to do is is i'm going
to grab my bullets i'm going to right
click on them i'm going to go to
simulation tags and i'm going to go to
rigidbody and that's going to place a
rigidbody tag on all of our our bullets
there
the first thing we want to do is
if we look at the collisions thing here
we have this thing called shape so
before i actually
um
do anything there i want to take this
down to
five and five right now um
we had 35 but want to take it to five
and five because i just want to
demonstrate something for you guys
so now if we go into our dynamics tag
here
um what we want to do is set this to
if we leave it at automatic and i go
let's go back to
frame 0 and then i move forward one
frame
the visualization is showing us what the
dynamic system is going to try to
calculate now although
this particular
um
object doesn't have a lot of polygons
when i start adding a lot of
objects in here like 35 or something
like that it gets really really really
slow so
we're going to actually use a trick
one
one way that you can actually make this
work
without having so many polygons is to
model a dummy object basically a proxy
object that has way less polys and it
will um you can use that to actually
calculate your simulation bake out the
simulation and then replace that proxy
object with the high poly
model that you created that's one way of
doing it another way of doing it is
actually telling the system here to look
at this object differently so since this
is a fairly sim cylindrical object
that's going in the y what we can do is
is i can say
cylinder axis y
okay
and let's go back and then go back to
the first frame and now you can see that
our bullet is represented by a much
lower poly object here which is going to
make our simulation go a lot faster
so now that we saw that i can actually
turn that visualization off and then we
can go back into our cloner
and go back into the cloner and we can
set this back to 35 and 35
so that we have the amount that we need
okay so that's ready to go let's go to
our floor here
and i am going to this is the width
segments of that floor
um and i'll show you why i made uh so
many segments so the first thing i need
to do is i need to come into our
deformers section
and i am going to add a displacer
and i'm going to put that here
and in the displacer
the strength should be 100 and then
we're going to make the height 16.
and what i'm going to do is grab the
displacement map from a texture that i'm
using for the floor and you'll see that
later which is right here
uh
i'm going to actually copy this
let me find the depth map which is here
we're going to use this 8k depth map
i'm going to hit no on that there
and now if you can see here what's
happening is that we can see a
representation
of what our floor is going to look like
with the uh displacement if we lower
the resolution of the segments of our
plane here it'll actually start to make
this really chunky now what this is
actually going to help us do it's
actually going to help us calculate our
simulation and make sure that when the
bullets fall
they hit in the right they hit in the
correct areas that they need to hit in
so that's going to be
very helpful when we're actually running
our simulations but the problem is is
that when we set this so if we come into
here and i go to cinema 4d tags
simulation tags we would set this to a
collider body since the bullets are
going to be falling and colliding with
it then we can go to collision if we set
this we're supposed to set this to
static mesh which is right if we do that
with this displacer on it's going to
make the simulation go really really
slow so what we want to do is is we want
to get our simulation kind of the way
that we want it falling and then we're
ready to bake out that simulation that's
when we'll turn on our displacer
which it could take a while for that
simulation to bake out that's when we
would turn onto our displacer and bake
out our simulation so that it'd be more
accurate but when we're just going
through and kind of building out the
simulation that's not necessary so the
next thing that we're going to do
is i'm going to turn off the displacer
we have our collider body on
okay so now for our floor we're going to
come into here we're going to actually
change our parameters here
and we're going to set this to
static mesh and then we're going to come
here and we want to turn
we want to turn off the bounce because
we don't want our
uh
bullets to be bouncing all over the
place
and then we want the friction to be 200
and the collision noise to be five so
with that there all we have to do is
grab this and i can apply that to my
helmet
and my colt
revolvers okay
we also want to apply this to our
cylinder but the cylinder itself is
going to have
the parameters on this guy is going to
they're going to be a little bit
different
let's get rid of that guy
so my cylinders here i'm going to take
this dynamics tag
i'm going to put it on the cylinder here
and we're going to change this to the
bounce to be 0 but we want the friction
to be about 15 percent because we want
these bullets to really slide down and
land onto our
onto our object and that looks pretty
good
so let me save this
and
that looks like that is pretty good so
let's go ahead and hit play on this and
see what we get
okay and it looks like
we have an issue here
okay let's try that again i didn't
really see anything wrong but
let's try that again
there we go and now they fall down and
they're falling through the hole and now
they're landing
on our
helmet there
cool i think that looks cool so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to go into my
i have a camera set up here
but we want to
kind of
make it work i have a camera set up here
it's at a 24 uh focal length kind of
wide there
i'm going to go into the coordinates and
i'm going to change
the pitch to 90.
oops minus 90 sorry
minus 90 not 900
there we go and then i'm going to move
this up
and now we're going to get
directly on it and as you can see i have
my composition helpers here with the
grid in the crosshair and it looks spot
on right there but i think i'm too far
out so i'm just going to move in
and then we're just going to move up to
frame that nicely there
and that looks good so let's see what it
looks like
uh when we bake the simulation and we
can watch it in real time so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to grab
my
dynamics tags here we're going to go
into the cache section here and we can
see this bake object option here so now
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
save actually just to make sure and then
we're going to bake those two objects
and that'll go through and bake that
simulation
okay so our simulation has finished and
let's take a look
and i think that looks good and lights
it flows right nicely over into the uh
the um character there we do have uh it
falling in the eye there but that's okay
you can notice a little bit of issues
where the bullet
is kind of going through
the um gun there so let me kind of show
you what's happening there
let's go back into our project settings
and we're going to hit enable
and you can see what happened is that
when i flipped the gun on its x-act on
its z-axis for some reason
it didn't change the direction of the
dynamics simulation and i'm not quite
sure how to fix that
but
that is not a big deal these are the
troubleshooting issues that you run into
when you are actually working with
dynamics you have to go in and kind of
keep
tweaking those settings to kind of
figure out that uh to get that correct
and make sure that it's falling off of
the gun correctly you can see it's kind
of falling through some of the parts
um not ideal but it does work in some of
the most of the areas and that's what we
want so the next thing that i'm going to
do is now that we have that simulation
there i don't really like how
the bullets are flying through the
camera like that so instead of actually
re-simming or moving the
the uh funnel
to direct my animation because i like it
i'm gonna just move the camera a bit
let's see if we can kinda
just reposition ourselves
yeah and that looks nice so
now it's kind of falling over top of the
camera as opposed to right through the
lens and i think that looks really nice
cool let's save that the next thing
we're going to do is we're going to
start to texture our scene so the first
thing we're going to texture is our
little or our floor here or excuse me
let's texture the helmet first i think
that's a good idea so i'm going to show
you how i do that in octane first we're
going to pull a plug in c4d octane and
i'm going to pull up the octane material
here i'm going to open up mine go to
basic and i'm going to open up my node
editor and this is what the node editor
looks like in octane if you guys are not
familiar
so i have my uh textures here and this
is the uh metal rusty texture that i
used on the helmet so what i can do is
i'm just going to move this off screen
and what i'm going to do is let's pull
up our
node editor
and i'm just going to grab
all of the passes that i need that came
with the download
and i'm just going to drop those in here
from my windows machine
it takes a second to load them they are
pretty big textures and there they are
they kind of drop in like that
let's help pull this out
so this is my roughness map so we can
take this
we'll just plug that into our roughness
it looks like this needs to be a
possibly a glossy texture so i'm going
to take this to glossy
okay and then here is our
normal map so we can just
place that there
this one is our
displacement so we need to come here
at displacement
usually in the displacement i uh i know
that this displacement is 8k
and i think i'm going to take it down to
like one
we're just gonna add that in there okay
and this should be our albedo which is
another term for our color
and i know on my albedo i want to
desaturate it a little bit
so i just put a color correction note
right between my uh albedo and my final
output and we're just going to pull down
the saturation
quite a bit i would say to about right
there
pull out some of that green
okay i'm gonna move my window off to the
side here
and apply this texture to our helmet
and you can see that there and that
really mapped nicely you can see how it
kind of
flows over the eye there
the next thing we're going to do is
texture our bullets
and we're going to use the same method
because let's just
let's just label this helmet helmet
let's go ahead and texture our bullets
so i'm going to create new
oh actually now that i think about it
what i ended up doing for that is
i use my textures that i bought from
grayscale gorilla
and let me show you how i actually
um grab those
open up my live viewer
and here i go to materials open live db
after you've installed the preset uh
materials
and
these are the grayscale gorilla textures
here
and i just went into the metal section
and then i used the brass
and the copper so
let's see here there's the brass i used
and there's some copper
that you can choose
from i'm actually going to pull that off
to the side and that's right here so
um here's the shell
so i can just apply that to that one
and then i also want to apply it to
the bullet here but i actually have some
texture tags texture selections
so if i look here um let's get out of
our camera
and i'm going to turn off our
cloner let's go in
so we can see it
and
yes that's the one we want so i'm going
to click that and i'm going to apply
that to that and then after and then
lastly i'll apply the copper
so it'll be for the tip
i just need to put that up front
and if we look now we have
the brass casing with the copper tip
okay so we can turn back on our cloner
now what we want to do is um texture our
gun so i'm going to create a
shader plug-ins
octane
octane
material and bring this back over here
and kind of scale out a little bit
and
the gun is fairly easy
to
texture also
so
here
here are all the
here's all the gun textures here
um
so i'm just going to move this off to
the side grab the ones i need and drag
and drop them like i did the other ones
all right sweet
so
this is our specular so
this actually needs to be
a glossy material
and then we can plug this into our
specular
you can plug this into our normal
we can plug this into our gloss which
would be our roughness
and then we can plug this into our
diffuse
and that's that
and we can apply that
what is this this is our bullets
and this is the gun
and we can apply that to the gun
for both guns actually
now i personally did not like the pbr
material for the colts here when i
rendered it they didn't look it didn't
look very natural so what i ended up
doing
is
creating some selection sets on the gun
by you know selecting those polygons and
then you know
going shift
c and then doing set selection
which is right here
let's close out of that
and so i also grabbed a gunmetal
material
from grayscale gorilla and i just place
that there
and then you know put in the
corresponding
polygon selections
to get a more realistic
gun texture now we can actually do our
this texture but i kind of want to show
you guys something and it's pretty cool
so where i got this ground texture
is from a site called real displacement
textures and this is like one of the
best sites for you know very high
resolution 3d scanned textures and
things of that sort and this is where i
got that particular uh texture
cg trader is where i got the helmet as
you can see right here this is the
deathstroke helmet i was telling you
about
here's the bullets casing uh
set that i bought
um i didn't add in all these bullets i
kind of wanted to add in the shotgun
shells for some color but i decided not
to do that and then this is the gun here
which is actually free so
the cool thing about real displacement
textures is is if i go to file
open
and i am going to navigate to my
textures for this project
will displacement textures actually
provide a
project file for you based on your
render engine
and it has a cineba 4d file it also has
an octane file and it also has a v-ray
file and it's already set up set up for
you so that whole process that i went
through to set up the textures for the
helmet and stuff like that you actually
don't have to go through when you use
these so i'm just going to open this up
and here's my texture and it's already
ready to go so what i'm going to do is
i'm just going to grab this one i'm
going to ctrl c
come back here into my main scene
and then i'm going to hit ctrl v
and i'm just gonna drop this onto my
plane
okay
and
it looks like the textures didn't
have the texture didn't link so
let me
use my trusty texture manager
i'm going to select all the textures
i'm going to edit and i'm going to go to
relink textures
i'm going to come in here
and i'm going to find my project file
which is right here and then i'm going
to go to textures and here's that one
i'm going to hit ok
and it has re-linked all of those
and then i'm going to select these
textures
hit edit reeling textures
come down
and hit okay
those are
pre-linked and then
let me uh
i'm not sure why that didn't re-link but
let's try to
get the gun texture linked to
what should be in my 3d models and i'll
hit okay
and we should be good now
let's uh open this up
cool all right so everything's linked so
now what i'm going to do is back out of
my scene here so you guys can kind of
see the lighting setup i have going on
here
so basically what i have here is just a
single area light
and in that area light i have a falloff
map and what i did was is go to
plug-in cinema 4d octane
and go to falloff map and this allows me
a little bit more control over the
distribution of the light and how um it
affects the scene so what i'm gonna do
is go back into my camera that i have
created and then i'm gonna go to my live
viewer window
and i am going to dock my live viewer
window right here
so we can see everything a little bit
better and i'm going to open up my
settings so you guys can see what my
settings are so right now i'm using path
tracing i have a max samples of 300 i
have a diffuse step of 8 specular depth
of 8 and then we also have a gi clamp of
one
so
let's close that and let's go ahead and
fire up our render and see what we get
okay and what i need to do is actually
scale that down a little bit so we can
see the full thing
and as you can see this is our lighting
setup here it actually looks really nice
right off the bat i didn't really have
to do too much um because i kind of had
it set up for us already um but if we
look at the you know kind of the way the
bullets are flying through the camera i
think that looks really cool and
cinematic
um i also turned on the motion blur
uh inside of
the
octane render engine or actually you
have to put on an object tag on each of
the
objects that you want to have motion
blur on them and that will add it to it
so if i go to the object tag
come here click motion blur
and then i go into my camera and then
activate motion blur there i have a
shutter of 0.1 there
um i can probably turn that up a little
bit but
i think it's fine for now
uh one thing i am noticing is that my
bullets are going too much through the
floor so in an octane displacement you
have this option to go to the mid level
and kind of bring that down oh
actually i want to
bring it up
so that we can see more of our bullets
there
and that looks a little bit more
accurate um
let's change this to four or five
maybe four
like seven
and yeah that looks like those are
laying on the uh laying on the surface
there
so yeah guys that is the basic workshop
for the dynamics animation um as you can
see we have a really nice scene here
minus motion blur you do see some issues
here where the bullet is actually
falling through the floor
kind of falling through the gun here
also so those those are going to be
those dynamic issues that i was telling
you about how this gun over here is
flipped this way so as a technical
artist also a motion designer like i
said nothing in motion design is easy i
would have to go through and technically
figure out what is going on here and how
to make that work maybe find a solve of
you know creating a proxy object for the
gun itself so that um you know it will
uh interact with the dynamics properly
um another thing too is the motion blur
that is a render issue so that's
something that i'll figure out um
um at another time but with that said
guys i really hope you kind of enjoyed
our overall workshop uh starting from
you know learning
the user interface inside of cinema 4d
what a lot of these parameters and stuff
mean and how to use them also the
lighting and
texturing course that uh that came right
before this one and hopefully you got
something out of this animation course
too so with that said guys i really
appreciate you watching um you guys take
care and i can't wait to create another
video for you guys in the future
alright take care
[Music]
you